vous AZ vu vous je sais pas si vous avez
eu le temps de voir aujourd'hui que vous
avez un soutien indirect qui est arrivé
de de Washington avec cette
communication du du FMI qui
effectivement soutient le relèvement de
de l'âge de la retraite de 2 ans en
Europe et notamment en France oui je
l'ai dit au sénateur ce matin le rapport
du FMI le directeur général et Dominique
stroskanan a dit que il fallait toujours
commencer une réforme de retraite par
augmenter l'âge légal de la retraite
c'est ce qu'on fait tous les autres pays
c'est ce que fait la France elle l' fait
de façon très raisonnable croyez-moi et
le FMI salue la réforme française merci
Dominique stroskanan vous dites
aujourd'hui oui merci Dominique
stroskanan au fond de ne pas être dans
une posture idéologique et uniquement
électoraliste mais d'être un homme
d'État responsable très bien merci
erriic V je vais vous laisser rejoindre
la séance qui va reprendre dans quelques
minutes a tour justement évidemment de
ce projet de retraite